which was the worst injury that you
suffered while making this film killing
I start with you and then work our way
down I mean we just do stunts
we have motors blow enough in our faces
so I mean I didn't really get hurt on
anything I to learn how to use a
motorcycle so I kind of dropped that a
few times over a tank but that's about
it okay you're walking which is good
yeah yeah I'm here I told you I an
injured the first take that I did in the
movie and I carried all through the
movie and but I didn't say that to
anybody because I didn't want for him to
think that I was just getting older but
it was just going running up the roof to
the helicopter it's just what first shot
I got a pain in my right knee and and
now he's gone buddy he just stay there
for a couple of months you're a trooper
I like it and sly I wake up with that
it's like breakfast no I mean I
literally usually I grade the quality of
a film by the intensity of the injury
like if I do stop on my mom will shoot I
never get hurt I do Rambo to expend as I
break my neck and my spine I heard just
the case both shoulders so on this one
here is like really taking a fall on my
back I had that some metal put in there
so if I'm squeaking okay it's not my
shoes it's my back snapped a shoelace it
was very depressing
now Jason actually saw death at the
bottom of the Black Sea he's very modest
about it just drove about a five-ton
truck 60 feet down into black mud
because I cut the brake line
that little reveal by the way Wesley I I
broke a nail in someone's eye when wince
live wanted to cut the brake line no I
didn't get too many injuries on this one
I made it out it made it out of it alive
negotiation you know what's so funny
that when we were sitting around and
actually I felt because that's Jason was
drowning I was filming with an iPhone I
guess I've been insensitive I don't know
I just thought you know this is a magic
moment and I can't help him anyway
because I would've drowned and
afterwards they pull him up he's pale
and he's changing and we go oh my god
and they're all sit around as
Expendables in a group line I wouldn't
jump in absolution would you say from
hell no I wouldn't go in I've drowned
the you know I like the guy but not that
much it's like all these real-life
heroes when they're actually confronted
in jeopardy or are you crazy get wet you
know but I mean I might get hurt you
crazy no no I can't swim well enough
great
so Jason at the moment like that you
really know who your friends are right
exactly yeah I'll never work with him
you have no friends
avi I presume you sustained no injuries
while making the movie but I imagine
scheduling these guys alone is a
backbreaker in itself I get the brain
surgery I need the brain surgery when I
see the price that they cost like this
but the worst part for me is actually to
to play tennis circuit a tennis elbow so
I want you to find when your pocket you
found all these fish hooks in there
instead of money having it no I mean
listen to me I want to say he's the
greatest he supports us this movie is
expensive and he stepped up and we're
really really proud of it it was not an
easy shoot he allowed us to have a
second unit of
550 the first unit what almost 600 Sal
we've we felt that we were really really
really competitive and I want to thank
you for taking all your money
there's no mic just there's a mic
there's a mic hallelujah there's a mic
doesn't work which magazine my
circulation but let me just think you
guys would talk about the kind of injury
you're gonna get would you is there
anything you kind of dude training wise
in the gym before the shoot starts to
kind of prepare your body to help you
prepare well you just there's just
something about you know you're going
across cinder blocks and gravel and
rebar and you trip and you bust up and
you get a back glass from you RPGs and
it gets serious it's um
it's kind of like a weird sporting event
when you do these Kent sort of films
you're good it's just like any sport
you're gonna get injured there's no
getting away from it is there anything
you find helps you recover or anything
there's no question that everyone
usually shows up really fit and goes
downhill from there you know you know
what you look like at 90 the violence in
this film seems to be less graphic than
the previous two is that a deliberate
thing
yeah I guess I'll talk about it well the
idea of pg-13 we wanted to hit a broader
audience and because of our Prentice
looking at the borns and and James Bond
we thought I mean they're pretty violent
films they're extremely graphic without
pushing it and of course when we do the
DVD then you'll see the next 80 frames
and there's hello there it is
but we thought we would convey it and I
thought also the amount of violence or
the amount of warfare in this movie if
it was graphic hippie after a while like
nauseated it's just almost too much even
though I personally enjoy it I just
think that it would be pushing the
envelope also with diminished the humor
for example Hail Caesar was going to die
literally and he kept saying don't kill
me don't kill me
don't tell me I said well you're doing a
TV show you have to die I'm sorry you
really want to do that show okay you
traitor and then he comes over and he's
always had tears in his eyes now I'm
sitting in with avi and it's something
like an execution you were sitting there
alone should we execute him no and am i
right in my life and we sit around and
it's an hour away he is going to die and
that was the whole premise Mel Gibson
kills him to say oh my god it's now on
you kill he'll see all right he dies but
he doesn't feel bad doesn't die that's
so guys is the dead one and oh I won you
have to see but anyway we just decided
to keep him around but also he's
mortally injured because of the idea it
just sets a tone that is almost mmm
irredeemable it's but it's just even at
the end that's a power because you've
lost a beloved person and that's the
difference between say are in pg-13 so
it's great for anyone doing pg-13 you
only get mortally wounded you don't get
fan that says hey there's no Chapman -
right at the frame right back this hand
up right from the front row right to the
back row
and then we'll get you guys in between
hey guys um thank you very much for
being here congratulations on a
fantastic film um my questions to sly I
think obviously there's a lot of new
faces in this film both young and old
and it really feels like there's a real
kind of spirit of passing of the torch
with this one I wondered if you can talk
a little bit about the people you
brought on board and and how much that
kind of spirit inspired the film okay I
mean I'll just speak quickly but I think
they should explain to themselves that's
out that it's at a point where we needed
to upgrade and retool and bring actors
that are known for their physicality but
they're also incredibly dramatic actors
nominated actors actors that have done
films almost in every genre and I
thought this would be interesting also
the age factor is that youth must be
served so we brought in a new generation
and it's almost like a parental thing
all children I think they know the
answer is they get in trouble parents
Kym to save them then they save their
parents anyway it's so it has a kind of
a family situation going but what did
you bring to it my friend
you I'm talking to you and you I see
these this type of movies always with
the possibility to have a wink of an eye
to the audience
I brought comedy they saw possibilities
in the character to just make people
have comical relief during the movie I
thought to Sly at the beginning and it
and the character was the design in a
way that allow me to do that
pretty clearly and he says you do
whatever and so I start playing with
that idea in mind I ended up improvising
a lot I mean this guy became kind of a
compulsive talker
a weapon of mass destruction of talking
and and when I saw my fellow actors
start rolling eyes I said yes I am
you know they just wanted to strangle me
basically in every scene and that
actually provokes some laughter
basically the character is just hiding
something painful inside and that's his
way to do it but right but I thought he
could be just adding a new color to to
everything that he was on the screen
already Wesley what do you feel like you
brought to it because we've worked
together and demolition man we know each
other very very well I've been waiting
to work with you ever since No thank you
were busy I was busy
opportunity to work with the whole squad
of extremely talented and iconic action
guys and actors I was looking forward to
that but I like Antonio tried to bring a
little bit of humor to the character and
you know a little bit more a little bit
of my martial arts action I could get
some any there's a duality between
Barney Ross and uh you know John smiley
for me you know you never really see the
young Barney and there's an essence of
who John is and how he becomes and you
know throughout the journey of the
script in potentially you know in four
or five six through ten ideally um
you'll see that developing him open up a
bit more and so you know my character he
doesn't smile you know he's he has a lot
of weight on his shoulders from his past
and you know Barney Ross gets in there
you know he's one of the few that can
actually get in there and so my
character is more of the drama queen I
guess but he'll open up you will through
ten is that a confirmation but going
through ten yes it is it is yes here
first I'm Jason as someone who's been
there from the very beginning I'm
expendable staple how do you react when
all these these youngins come onboard
and and
I think it's necessary it's a necessary
evil let them get beat up for a while
that's great we love that no it's it's
wonderful what
for example Ronda Rousey's not here but
there was no debate will Ronda Rousey
she's she's not really an actress she's
a fighter I said no she's she's a new
kind of entertainer and we're now
becoming a lot a lot of us are hybrids
whereas you just you're the antonio's
directed he's written he writes and so
does Wesley and Jason as all these other
sides to them and I thought well let's
take someone from a world MMA and I
couldn't have been luckier or more right
this girl is one of a kind she's very
sexy and she also can tie you into it
not in every Thailand and be charming
and she's you know still raw and
learning on the job but we've got
something special then you have Victor
Ortiz who's like a real world champion
you have real world champions in here
not just you have professional athletes
there's no championship team so you
haven't you have just a real a hybrid
instead of just all actress because I
don't think it could have been
accomplished it was just all actors
there's some skills there that take an
entire lifetime to learn and that's what
we were blessed with by getting to
employ those skills and Jason's gone
away on that one I think you said so you
who like really manly like girl men that
I wouldn't know what the like any
manicures between you how many bubble
baths you have all right
a mani-pedi petty man usually buffing
along the curbstone
like this either getting out of a car oh
yeah me too yeah well I like manicures
you joked about before through tang but
how far do you plan in advance do you
get ideas and think oh that will go for
the next movie and I'm bearing in mind
that this talk when expended bells at
some point okay are there any women that
you would like to see in that yes there
are and we're now starting to see that
you don't have
I can totally depend on actresses per se
pure you're gonna need a certain kind of
physicality to pull that off getting
back to how many Expendables I mean
what's the deal how many do you want
about 27 okay Jason how many do you have
patience for well how many Expendables
before it says alright I'm done I want
to be an Expendables well the idea is to
make at least another two or three
you'll see how in other words I'm joking
here but we'd like to just continue this
because it's it's an ongoing experiment
to you have a great franchise and the
Avengers and all that situation where
you can branch off and do other things
ideally I would love to see some of
these characters like Antonio or the
young Expendables go off to their own
movies I know that's may be a pipe dream
and then you come together for the big
festival of violence or the great
challenge of whoever the villain is but
that would be that would be the ideal so
I think I think it all depends on this
one here but I could definitely see one
and a half at least for this maybe two
more and then you never know but the
third one I've always found is when I
started doing something we've been
franchise I was
you'll for it we're all worse but I was
always they treat with television how
can they do ten years of the same
character you know all in the family
same location and yet you watch it but
you did one film ago I like to be that's
the end some films are designed like
that but other films are characters that
continue to grow and manifest different
personality changes now with the
Expendables you got a situation here
where we're in uncharted waters to put
all women together
will that really work or do you have to
put in fur cap perhaps some women that
are actually really known to be tough
other MMA fighters and and then is it
are the Expendables really part of a
divorce with Barney and say Sigourney
Weaver was my wife and she inherited
half the expandables so that's that's
like oh I got to deal with that too I
lost the house and my mercenaries in my
god trying to concoct so when we do it
it doesn't just languish there as it oh
it's just a use of the name it actually
is something that would hold its own so
sounds like you'd like to face off
against the Avengers old buddy sly is
that the idea
Expendables versus the Avengers that's
where you're going yeah yeah if we could
we be the earthbound Avengers there's a
chap here in the front row the blue
shirt there's a question for Wesley the
previous two Expendables they've always
um accentuated the enjoyment that
they've had on set and it's been a real
sort of locker-room atmosphere I
wondered whether that was a relief
coming making your comeback whether to
come into that sort of atmosphere was
very blokey and you could make a joke of
things oh absolutely I loved it I loved
it I mean it's like you can imagine
being on an Olympic team or Olympic
sports team of some sort where you got
some of the best of the best players all
playing at the same time so you get the
same kind of
interaction and into play and crack
jokes with each other and all of these
guys are quite funny in their own right
so yeah you could there's a lot of fun
with it
okay so you don't mind that I'm writing
Escape from Alcatraz too for you
Christopher both sly and Evie getting
back to the Expendables
I was talking to Jacqueline Bisset this
morning and she'd love to play the
villain if that film ever comes off we
never thought about as a villain but
look about Expendables we are right now
in the families of their script we have
got lots of idea about who is going to
be all the the action movie star like
this woman and we plan to do it
beginning of next year and that's all I
can say about this movie right now
Sylvester you're the Godfather of the
Expendables franchise how do you balance
working on the script and then getting
all these wonderful actors to join you
how do you tailor it to sit there skills
you just hit it there's it's really a
finite number of actors that I think
that bring a certain kind of cachet or
personality that would that blends so
you try to not get two of the same if
you know what I mean and I have
long-term relationships with people that
I didn't realize before they go back but
I thought oh okay we done Expendables
one or two now we have to up the game I
think Antonio Anthony hasn't done an
action film but he's very physical he
can do it so it answer your question
it's very very time-consuming it takes a
long time to convince some people a lot
literally
calling them on your birthday you're
there for like four hours but yeah you
know it's my birthday
do we favor yes it's my birthday I'm
talking to you from do a lot of begging
and cajoling it'sit's wild and some just
immediately you know I called Harris
before okay and Mel wants to know about
the part originally I wanted meld in
direct and I thought any but Mel is such
a great director and everything is so
personal it has to come from him but he
goes I wouldn't mind playing a villain
wins sold sold
uh Antonio were you the the gentleman
that sly called on his birthday by
chance he seems to be that's right he
was the parking lot okay beautiful
future franchises and stuff like that so
he said absolutely we became very good
friends actually since we did work
together I realize last night but we
actually not together but in one of his
PI kids are three what's my franchise
I should get some choice no it's getting
really personal I'm gonna bring boozing
boots I can't what were your
negotiations like was lying you know
this this dates back to 2009 when the
first Expendables came around and
there's a young expendable in that one
and I auditioned was during the twilight
years and for some reason we were just
talking about this out of black guy and
scraps from some stunt I was doing so
sly like that he's like are this kid can
take a hit you know he likes doing this
stuff and then do two dates and then
rewriting the script and taking the
character out that that character wasn't
in there so it's kind of bummed and then
the third one came around and you know
it's a whole Legion of young Expendables
got to meet with avi on Hercules and he
kept on pushing Expendables 3 and the
meetings for Hercules and I'm like what
about Hercules you know you're thinking
about me for this was like yeah yeah but
Expendables 3 were thinking about doing
this so um yeah from day one I want to
be a part of it
huge action junkie you know huge fan of
Jason's and sly and Arnie and you know
all these guys he got you uh played in
here he goes or oh you got three
vampires on this dais
thank you bad so there's a no-brainer
I want separate movies so yeah I met
with sly and I went up to his house we
talked the character and you know he
gave me the stamp of approval his his
daughters were Twilight fans so that
always helps
Wesley what were your negotiations like
so again what were your negotiations
like with with sly for this distant did
he just call very easy very very young
we told him how much is it getting when
is it coming
pretty much Jason now is the one he
Cortana on his birthday
no he's i remember we set them for we
had a lunch together and he said you
want to come to work and I said what's
the role and uh he said no just need
someone to make more sandwiches my chefs
died as question for sly and Wesley you
mentioned working together on demolition
man was there at any point any talk of
dyeing your hair blond again to do these
Simon Phoenix oh yeah I dare you ask me
I his hair blind again I refused that
was a lot of work man I thought wow
maybe his hair fell off yeah and we had
we've had to buy some most blonde and
vivid every morning hi there Duncan from
den of geek I just wanted to ask the
panel actually because you've had a lot
of great action in your careers if you
have like a favorite moment be a fight
right stunt scene or a car chase that
you're particularly proud of one that
really stands out from from any film
you've done mmm killing a worker way
down what was it just favorite scene
yeah any kind of favorite action scene
he's done you know I mean honestly being
a part of this movie that's that's to
date you know I've done only a few
action movies I love doing action movies
but the one that stands out is when all
of us were in the helicopter we have you
know a slot running I'm not gonna give
the end of the movie or anything but
just having that everyone who I grew up
watching in a helicopter together and
just cracking jokes yeah Victor ortíz
farting you know and you're kind of
locked in harnessed in so you can't fall
out of the helicopter so you know
imprisoned by the gas interesting image
those stunts are no and anything that
has to do I proud anything that has to
do with horses and soul fighting in
sorrow I put a lot of interest and time
into those things so I am proud of that
actually it's like I just had I've had
I've been lucky I've had so many
interesting ones I've you know falling
through trees in first blood doing the
last third of the tree get wiped out I'm
really proud of matter of fact I filmed
in a slow motion because I didn't know
if I was gonna get murdered killed on it
winner and in Rambo 3
there was no CGI and one is we almost
get hit by a helicopter literally on
horseback in a second one's playing the
booze Kazi game where it's it's a real
game where you play with the body of a
dead sheep it's a it's a Afghan game and
that was done for real but overall I
would say the dealing with Dolph
Lundgren and in rocky for that was
brutal I mean really brutal he was so
unbelievably powerful it's hard to
describe me I mean the US would killed
me so but the idea of having no ones you
sustain you say oh I'm action beats
hanging from a cliff hanger worth was
absolutely amazing because I hate
Heights and it's 4,000 feet how they
talked me into this
I don't like being in cowboy boots even
that's do a lot what am I doing here
but the the idea of sustaining a
15-round fighting you know that it took
six months so it's really one long stunt
that that that is what I'm proud of
because I know I could never even come
close to doing that again today so
thanks Dolph for the injuries that
denies you do a lot of different things
riding jet skis and I think one that
sticks in my memory would possibly be
I'm gonna fistfight outside a helicopter
standing on the skids and a movie called
crank I think that was
quite a treadle infield it was a pretty
scary moment because Wesley took off
from the top of a tall building so there
was no sort and adjustments are sort of
leaving the ground you can sort of
adjust and get used to it but we you
know we took up a building that was
already 2,000 feet in the air so I
didn't go over the edge you get you know
as serious sort of rush I think that one
sticks in my mind I'll never forget that
day imagine that Wesley yeah I think I
recall like one of the most memorable
stunts was wearing 14 inch sized
three-inch heels with John Leguizamo and
she was and running down the street that
was pretty hairy it was it was rough it
took a lot I think expendable three is
the biggest section movie that I've done
and I've done many it's really got
everything there in this movie from
trained helicopter boat guns you name it
it's in this movie and you will see in
the movie there's a chaplain here in the
fourth row thank you
like I served my beetle sueing magazine
and machines have a lot of fun when you
make these movies and as you said
there's a great blend of personnel what
I'm interested to know is how much does
that bring a friendly rivalry slash
competitive edge between you when you're
on set in terms of trying to outdo each
other I respect these guys greatly you
know and I'm also a fan of their work so
the opportunity to work with them and
then find out not only are they real
guys but they have very wide colorful
personalities and I can resonate with
them that's that's just icing on the
cake yeah and I never played a real team
sport so this is about the closest I've
gotten good being on a on a team it is
like a team really your team's for you
right everyone just says very very
healthy egos and athletic ability and
some of very very good actors and you're
gonna be competitive nobody wants to be
the one sitting there and looking like a
piece of chewed string at the end of the
scene you think hmm boy that I get wiped
out so you just you do your best so
inviting these actors there's like what
I'm working with Harrison Ford
he's like minimalist but when and I'm
like oh god I'm just eating him up on
screen and then I see the dailies ago
you were just swallows like yeah he's
good you know I mean it just he's
they're very very very good very good
so I appreciate them coming on board and
I I think we we have eons to go now that
like if I just see there's so many other
actors that you can bring even Kelsey
Grammer but are you kidding me Kelsey
Grammer Kelsey Grammer is amazing and
he's got a incredible range so you could
use him the beginning of the plot of
Expendables for here knocking on door
hey Kelsey what's up oh let me explain
to you what's going on and another one
you just have so many opportunities now
because it's not just athletic actors
there's an opportunity now for just
real actors to do athletic things and
make it just just advance the project
more more more question for Advan what's
it like working with such a talented
array of actors and who's the easiest to
work with and more importantly who's the
most difficult
there's nobody easy to work with and
nobody but look who's the most difficult
Sylvester stirlitz right
Harry Harry Knowles is here and my great
friend he knows we worked together on
Spy Kids and he knows who I'm just a
pushover he don't believe in the keys
the harmony and that's what with the
help and a minute of those lies is the
one of the main actor in the movie but
he's also a director he's also right
there he serves the coffee - all day and
every morning he does the Wardrobe and
so on but with the help of sly and all
these great actors we have seven
franchise actors in this movie seven
that's never happened before
so it's a on one fight was a challenge
but on the other hand it's I'm very
happy